independence day 2016.
juno arrives at jupiter
and gets to work
the probe angles its high resolution
camera towards this stormy world
juno's snaps do not disappoint
[Music]
the images returned from juno are just
beautiful
[Music]
suddenly you have this magnificent
mosaic of this planet
as a human being i'm like oh my gosh
look at this it's amazing this is coming
back from jupiter
these are the closest ever views of
jupiter a world 500 million miles away
[Music]
but we didn't send juno just to take
pictures
one of its main goals is to peer deep
into jupiter's dark heart
one of the big questions we have about
jupiter is does it have a core
and you'd think well of course it has a
core like every planet has a core the
earth has a core everything does
well it turns out jupiter might not
knowing what lies at a planet's core
allows scientists to wind back the clock
billions of years to the formation of
the planets
if juno can reveal what lies deep within
jupiter it could change our
understanding of how the gas giant
formed
if juno finds a solid core it could mean
jupiter first formed as a rocky planet
like earth then kept growing
but if juno finds no core it could mean
that jupiter skipped the rocky stage and
formed straight from a cloud of gas
answering this question could shine a
light on other mysteries too
if we can figure out how jupiter formed
we can figure out the rest of the story
of the solar system
so how do you probe down into the
interior of a planet when all you can
really see are the very tops of the
clouds
well incredibly you can use gravity
as juno orbits jupiter
it can sense
in its orbit tiny little variations in
the gravitational pull of jupiter
as juno speeds around jupiter
gravitational spikes tug on the craft
turns out some parts of jupiter are
denser than others
if jupiter were some solid ball then as
juno passes by it as it passes very
close above its cloud tops
the orbit the trajectory would be very
smooth but in fact
if jupiter has layers or places where
there's more mass and places where
there's less then it's going to pull on
juno a little bit differently
passing over areas of concentrated mass
gives juno a speed boost
so what they do is the engineers back on
earth can basically just say how fast is
it moving right now how about now how
about now and you build up a map of
where the mass is in jupiter
underneath the spacecraft as it passes
around
juno's instruments begin to map out the
heart of the gas giant
revealing the mysterious core
for the first time
what juno found was this amorphous mass
a fuzzy thing in the center of jupiter
it's not as solid as we expected if it
were just a metal and rock core
but there is something there
in the center of the planet juno detects
hydrogen and rocky material dissolved
and blended together
it's a type of planetary core we've
never seen before
astronomers describe it
as fuzzy
we thought we were going to find an
avocado instead we found a bowl of chili
it's a hydrogen fluid chili con
carne so none of our models of the
interior of jupiter turned out to be
correct that means we have to go back to
the drawing board
one theory is that jupiter didn't form
from rocks or gas
but from tiny pebbles less than an inch
wide strewn across the early solar
system 4.6 billion years ago
these pebbles came together they
accreted to form a massive object that
was the sort of seed the core of jupiter
the swarm of pebbles clumped together to
form one giant core 20 times the mass of
earth
but these pebbles can't sustain this
growing planet for long
eventually we need to make a jump from
those centimeter-sized particles up to
really large things like 100 kilometer
planetesimals to really kick-start
growth of a planet
as jupiter grows its appetite becomes
insatiable
the cores of other would-be planets are
drawn in by its immense pull and absorb
on impact
causing jupiter's core to
transform
huge chunks of incoming rock are mixed
up with gas and the pebbles that
originally built the core
we think that the core material that
might have been there is actually
dissolved and mixed in with the rest of
the planet
this mix of rock gas and pebbles leaves
the core in a strange state somewhere
between solid and liquid
or in other words
fuzzy
once jupiter's core reaches a critical
mass its gravity pulls in all nearby
hydrogen gas
building the jovian atmosphere
and leaving the fuzzy core trapped
beneath thousands of miles of thick
clouds
and that is what formed jupiter as we
know and love it today
juno's discovery of jupiter's fuzzy core
could rewrite the book on jupiter's
early years
but juno is just getting started we
haven't even scratched the surface of
the number of mysteries there are
there's more to jupiter than meets the
eye as juno's instruments begin to
reveal a darker side to this giant world
jupiter's environment is one of the most
vicious in the solar system and that's
because of its incredibly strong
magnetic field
and juno is caught right in the middle
of it